JAN MIKSOVSKY: OK.
Hi.
My name's Jan Miksovsky.
And for the next
10 minutes, I want
to give you a quick preview of
a new part of the web component
ecosystem.
As you look at a new
technology like this,
I think it's helpful to look
beyond the technological
accomplishment, and
consider the question,
how will this change
what people can create?
And I think any time you have a
space where people make things
and you introduce the
idea of components,
you fundamentally
change what people
can create at a
really deep level.
And you're bringing a huge
number of new building blocks
within people's
reach that they can
use-- it'll amplify what
they can already do,
so that they can create
something new they couldn't
have made before.
In the case of web
components, I think
it's quite interesting that
because the material of web
components is HTML, the
change that it'll bring
will not just be
deep, but quite broad.
Far beyond the audience
of traditional developers,
the benefits of
web components will
extend to anyone
who can use HTML.
And there are a lot
of those people.
So think about
all the people you
know who are designers,
marketers, writers,
small business
owners, individuals
that have at any
point touched HTML.
There are a lot of those people.
The fact they
don't even always--
aren't using
traditional dev tools.
Many times they're
editing a site
in the context of a hosted
environment, so Squarespace
or Drupal or Wordpress.
And as long as the site
gives them the ability
to edit bits of HTML inside
that hosted environment,
they can create things.
And because web
components are just HTML,
it means the technology
has the potential
to amplify what those
HTML-level authors can create.
All that's necessary
is that the ecosystem
expand to include them.
And so a few months ago,
a friend of mine and I
founded Component
Kitchen, because we
wanted to help bring that about.
We think that this
is going to be
fascinating,
transformative technology.
And we wanted to help bring
web components to a mainstream
audience so that we can
help them understand what
the technology can
do for them, and then
help them find great
web components that'll
let them make their
own work shine.
So tonight, we wanted to
give the first public preview
of our service.
So I'm going to start by
showing the basic thing
that we're starting with, which
is a catalog of components.
There will be other
catalogs, other registries.
Our take that we're
going after is
we'd like to make this available
to a mainstream audience,
so that starts by taking the
ideas that have been proven out
in well-designed app
stores and online stores
and applying them
to this domain.
So for starters,
we want to make it
as visually engaging as possible
so people can understand
what they're looking at.
And we want to bring in the
now-traditional community
aspects of stores, like
ratings and reviews
and recommendations, along
with tools like tutorials
to help them understand
what this can do for them
and also help them find the
components they're looking for,
things that will solve the
problems that they have.
We're going to walk through
just three quick examples.
So I'll start with a
really basic component.
This one happens to
put an interactive map
onto your website with
a little bit of HTML.
And the author of
this component didn't
have to do anything special.
They make the source
available on GitHub.
And they register
it with a service
called bower that makes it
discoverable by our site.
We can go to that
source repository
and extract data about
this component, metadata
on the left, things like
a read-me on the right.
So these are just basic details.
And by pulling information
on all the components
that have been made available,
and pulling that together
in a site, we can
advocate for the consumer
of these components,
because we can allow them
to quickly compare components
and assess the value of those
so that they can quickly find
the particular one that's
going to solve their need.
Now a read-me file
tends to be something
that's written for a more
technical audience, people who
want to understand the
construction of something.
But here, this
audience is primarily
interested in using components.
And they want to use them
at the level of HTML markup.
That's what they understand.
So let's look at
another example.
This is actually a component
that Eric showed earlier.
This is the geolocation
component he mentioned.
And what he's done in the
source for his component
is he's annotated the
source code with comments
that follow a
particular convention.
And what that lets
him do is then
those comments describe what
attributes that component
supports, in language that's
meaningful to a wider audience.
So for example, someone coming
to this can see, OK, I get it.
There are going to be new custom
attributes on this component
that other components
don't have.
These are unique to this
geolocation one, including
things like the
latitude and longitude,
so they can make
sense at their level
for what these
components can do.
For the third and
last example, I'd
like you to consider--
imagine for a moment
that you're not someone who's
intimately familiar with web
development, but instead someone
who works at the level of HTML.
Maybe you work in a small
team or an organization that
doesn't have dedicated
development staff.
And occasionally, you
have as part of your job,
maybe it's not your
primary responsibility,
but occasionally you need
to go and edit some HTML.
And let's imagine you're
adding a form to your website.
And you want to collect
some data from the user.
And in this particular
example, let's imagine
that you're going to have a
text area into which your end
users can type in some text.
Maybe when you create
this form, you'll
be surprised or
disappointed by the fact
that the standard
HTML text area doesn't
grow in size as your
users type into it.
This is surprising or
disappointing to you,
because when you go to a
polished, large-scale site
like Facebook and you
type in a status area,
you see that box automatically
growing as your typing.
You thought that that
was part of the web.
Silly you.
So you'd like to have-- you
wish that you could give
your own users, the users of
your site, that same ability.
So until now, that was
probably beyond your abilities
as an HTML author.
In order to solve that problem,
you need to know JavaScript
and you need to know how the DOM
works at a certain level, what
events you need to wire up.
It's fairly complex.
The good news with
web components
is that somebody can wrap
up a solution like that
and create a thing you can use.
It's not a recipe
like you might find
on a site like Stack
Overflow, where
you have to follow a
bunch of instructions.
It's a thing you can search
for and then get a result for.
So this is an example
of a component
that might fit the bill.
This particular page is one
we're using as a proving ground
to test out some
ideas that we'd like
to enable for all
components in this catalog.
There's two interesting
things going on here.
The first is the
centerpiece of the page
is a live demonstration
of that component,
because that's really
going to-- that's
what's going to sell
you on using it.
So here as an HTML author
exploring the site I can see,
yeah, this is the kind
of thing that I want.
I want that.
And then right below
it, you can see the fact
that-- you can see
the HTML fragment that
created that demo.
They're live, so
you can edit one
and see how it affects
the demonstration.
And as an HTML author, this
is quite reassuring to you.
There's nothing--
aside from the fact
that there's this
new tag you've never
seen before, the syntax
is familiar to you.
The idea that you
can set attributes
on it and type stuff inside the
tags, that's all stuff you get.
So all you need to
focus your attention
on are, one of the
attributes here
that are unique
to the component?
Again, we can
extract information
about those attributes from the
source code of the component
and create here on the
right a little editor
that lets you
experiment with them.
So perhaps in this example
you want your users
to feel comfortable
typing in a bit of text.
And so you decide that
what you want to do
is give them a larger
initial size to this box.
It's always going to be
at least five lines tall.
As you edit this
custom attribute,
you see it updates the
attribute in the markup example
down below.
So you get, OK, this
is how I'm going
to accomplish this in HTML.
And it updates the
demo so you can
see how that's going to
affect the final presentation,
the experience your
users will have.
OK.
So now you've found
the auto-sizing text
area of your dreams.
And you want to add
this to your site.
So today, if you're not a web
developer, the tools of web
development, things like
GitHub or npm, these tools
that web developers get,
those are unfamiliar to you.
So telling you to go
use those tools is not
going to be very meaningful.
So now we get to the second
part that we'd like to enable.
And that's to take advantage
of a core web component
feature, which is HTML imports.
We can host on the
Component Kitchen site
a copy of a component
that you can
reference in HTML from any site.
So as the author
trying this out,
you can click Copy to Clipboard
and then go into whatever tool
you use to edit HTML.
It can be anything.
I'm going to just use the
simplest one I can find,
so there's HTML on the left and
then the output on the right.
And you come to an
editor like this
and then paste in the code.
And here we see a live version
of that running on your site.
So on the left,
what's happened is
we've got the little bit of
HTML which you customized
on the site to get it to
look the way you wanted.
Above that it's also
grabbed a script tag
that loads that platform.js
library the Polymer guys talked
about, as well as an HTML
import that references
a hosted version of this
component hosted at our site,
so that you can
use this anywhere.
All you needed was HTML.
So I want you to think for
a moment about if you're
someone who deals with HTML
in a site like Squarespace
or Wordpress, things like that,
think about how transformative
this will be for
what you can create.
Here's something
you wanted to be
able to do that until
yesterday was something
that was too difficult.
And now it's something, it's
just a matter of cut and paste.
So you can see that this skill
you have, just the ability
to feel comfortable
looking at HTML
and editing it, that skill
you have has suddenly become
amplified to be so much
more valuable and powerful.
It's the existing
skill you have.
And suddenly now you're
able to create new stuff.
If you think about
whatever it is
you do in your day
job, your organization,
your company There may be some
service or some interaction
that you would like other
people to offer on their site.
I think a web component
will be a great way for you
to deliver that.
And at Component Kitchen,
what we want to do
is help you find
that audience, help
people find your component,
understand what it can do,
and then use it.
So that's almost all
the time I've got.
I did want to point
out-- I'd encourage
you to check out the site.
It's component.kitchen.
Yay for new top-level domains.
And there's a link to
an RSS feed we offer.
We've already found
this pretty useful.
It tracks all new components
that are published.
So if you wanted to see
what people are doing,
this is a good way
to find out about it.
And then finally,
I'd encourage you,
if you've got your phone handy,
your laptop, go to Twitter.
Follow us on @ComponentK.
We'd love to hear
what you think.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Jan.
All right.
Thanks.